You have a seat.
- I'm so nervous
I'm telling y'all I gave them their,
I give vinyl to everyone that
comes to the show and I
gave yours to them and I
I've done it a bunch actually.
You're welcome for the sales.
But, but if you, if you're like,
where is all my vinyl going
Kelly Clarkson's buying it, but no, I just
but your whole look, your
whole vibe like was this
I have to ask, was this all
thought out from the beginning?
Because even how y'all
sing in unison, I mean
usually people will double
your vocal, you know
to have that kind of effect.
But it's cool because
you have different tones.
- Yeah.
- Was it all like, set out
like that in the beginning to do the kind
of unison thing and synchronize thing
and then separate and
harmony and the whole style?
Was that all from the beginning?
- Well, in the beginning,
I mean, basically
we just both wanted to sing lead
And we couldn't decide how
- Love the honesty in that.
How are we gonna do this?
- Yeah.
- So, you know, we were in the studio
we were doing a rearrangement of a song
from the White album.
And so we started both
singing at the same time
while our cans were on.
And it was like, oh,
that's really cool. It's
like a double track vocal
- Yeah
- Except we could do this live.
How cool would that be?
- And except you have,
you're able to blend well
but your tones are slightly different
than it makes that Oh
- Yeah.
Magic.
- Thank you.
You know, we like old
school showmanship and
and old school, you know, girl groups
and people that make a thing
of their, their look and
Yeah.
- Dress the sound.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Dress the sound.
So trying to something that, you know
sort of transports us
and transports our audience
And then
- well done.
We got carried away.
- I love it though
like this whole performance
art that's happening as well
with how you perform, how you look.
Like you still keep
individuality but look similar.
It's very cool.
- Thank you.
I'm just gonna compliment you
this whole interview.
Okay.
"The man I'll never
Find" is the song you're
gonna be singing today.
The whole album.
Mind you, this song is amazing
but the whole album is amazing.
It's just, I specifically when
I heard this song was going
through a really hard
time and divorced and I
I don't know if I've wept
like that in a very long time.
So, so I'm angry about
it, but also Thank you.
But it just, it's, it's one
of those things I feel is so special and
and rare sometimes cuz people
in this business and you know
they just want you to do a hit
and they want you to
like just do something
out that's catchy and people remember
for a minute and whatever.
And it's not always long lasting.
And I think it's just a great job
of like really being a poet, like
and really saying how your heart was.
And like it's just the most amazing thing
for us to listen as fans to
music and connect in that way.
You do an awesome job of that.
Like, have you, do you find
yourself to be singers first
or writers because
geez it's a hard tug of war there for me.
It's a hard one.
- Yeah.
Yeah, I don't know.
It's, it's such a different
head space I think.
Like
- Yeah.
And we're not able to write
really on the road when we're
in like tour mode.
It's really hard to write.
Some people are good at that.
- Yeah.
I don't do that either.
- We gotta compartmentalize.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- I mean I think it was easy
to write at a time I was going
through a divorce.
- Yeah.
- And we sat down to write
and then pandemic hit us.
So we really were gifted
- All this this time,
- All This time, all this
drama, all this difficulty
honestly that we could
all relate to clearly.
Yeah. Unfortunately.
- Unfortunately
- Getting a divorce so and a hit.
Yeah.
- You got something out of it.
Yeah. It is hard though to bear.
It's, it's taken me, God
I don't even know how
many years it would be
since my last like to,
I had to tell my label.
I was like, I can't talk about it yet.
Like I can't be interviewed about it yet.
So like I can't release the album yet.
It took me that long.
Yeah. To even say yes to releasing it.
Like, did it take you a minute?
Like when it's something that
personal to like release it
out or is it therapeutic
for you in that sense?
- It was therapeutic.
I mean I think it was difficult
to start writing about it
and then once we did,
you know, she's been what
we have a unique thing because
we're traveling together
she's seeing my life and I'm seeing hers.
We're witnesses to each
other's life and we're
songwriting partners so we're
really able to write on behalf
of the other person
- Yeah.
- In a very, you know,
sort of special way.
Intimate way.
Yeah. Yeah.
And so by the time we
sat to write it was clear
that it was over and
- Yeah.
You know, it was, it was easier
to actually just pour it out
and then once you get it
out, it's somebody else's
you get to give it to
somebody else for whatever it
is that they're gonna, how
however it is that they're
gonna receive it.
- Receive it.
Yeah. So that's, that's
kind of how it happened.
- Did you do you do this thing
where you write what you really wanna sing
and then you have to
kind of filter yourself.
- You're Like, "I'm gonna bring that back.
That was too much."
- I think that's what we're for.
- Oh, okay.
Yeah, I don't have that.
- Unfair advantage.
- I'm just, it's just
Me going "Was that too?
I think it might have been too much.
I think that's too much."
So I love this too.
You ended up recording the, the,
it's "The Man I'll Never Find" is the one
you recorded at Cheryl Crow's right?
You ended up staying at Cheryl Crow's
recording music which is like your,
your life is like Rolling Stone.
- Yeah. That's crazy.
- Like, I'm like, wait, what?
Yeah. That's crazy.
Does she just have like a studio there?
Like you were hanging out in?
She does.
- Okay.
- And she has a piano in her living room.
That's the most beautiful sounding room
you've ever heard.
- Aw.
And we sat to write and it just
poured out really
- Yeah.
- And she's just such, am
I allowed to say badass?
- Oh, she's a badass. Watch this.
- Badass
- A badass
Yeah. I don't know if you can say it.
I'm gonna say bleep it, badass
She is, she's so incredible.
And like her story's incredible.
- Yeah.
- And the fact that she
like is the same artist
and I feel like Brandy's like this.
I feel like a lot, I know a lot of artists
like this that are, that are like,
"Oh man, I'm gonna, I'm
gonna help you get to where
you wanna go. I'm gonna help
you like shine brighter.
I think that's the best way to be.
- Totally.
- And I feel like she's
one of those artists.
- She's so cool.
- Also, she has a magical
studio that we should all record
music in cuz Apparently
the best songs come out
of the studio.
- Lucius' new album is
called Second Nature.
Don't be dumb, get it.
You're welcome in advance.